i have a team here that came with one
idea and they already pivoted uh two or
three times we have a team
that came in and people look at the idea
and they were like
what like how am i even supposed to
analyze this i've never heard of
something like this
and we said okay here's 100k let's work
together
[Music]
thank you for joining me on 20 minute
leaders how are you
thank you for having me it's great to be
here calling straight from the f2
offices right
yes actually um as you said the lighting
wasn't that good in my office on the
bottom's office so
it's my aspiring position i i love that
uh i i definitely love that tal
can't wait to talk about precede f2
capital and the junction and that one of
my best friends mickey
koslowski also had the pleasure of being
a part of uh but also about
about the interesting journey of of both
being you know one arm
and startup scene one arm in the
investment scene and you know
cross-bordering the the insights but
before we get there
tell me a little bit about your journey
and how do you find yourself in venture
capital
sure well you know i actually told this
story a few times um
so do you want to start from south
africa and where i was born or should i
go
straight forward to me uh joining the f2
if we had enough time we would go back
to when your parents were born but we'll
start skill reborn
okay cool so uh i'm originally from cape
town south africa i moved to
when i was five with my parents
um i'm not going to go into back my
whole childhood story but
when i was 18 i joined the army i joined
the special forces intelligence unit
and then after the army after six years
there serving as a combatant and
captain uh when south idc business
and part of my studies i did an exchange
program at usc university of southern
california
so i was about i don't know 26 at the
time
and then all the others around me were
about i don't know
youngest like 18 straight up after high
school into college and
some of the other exchange guys were
like 21 22.
and in israel it's not common to to have
internships and
all all my friends were like yeah i'm
going back home i'm going to be working
for morgan stanley jp morgan man
mckenzie and listen and i was like man i
have a semester that
i have nothing to do what should i what
should i be up to so i decided to be
proactive and reach out to a bunch of
vcs on linkedin until this day i say
that any vc
in israel if they go into their linkedin
inbox they'll find a message from me
from like
2017 saying hi my name is taiwan i work
for you
none i think none of them responded
seriously one dead
uh johnny sacks from uh from f2vc
um and before that of course he was a
genesis he said that's
it for coffee um i came
to to meet him i asked to join he said
no i said please he said okay
that's that's a short version and two
days after i started
at f2 and since then i've been at the
fun for
three years wow tell me a little bit
about that
about some of the you know the insights
that you've had at f2 but also about
what f2 is all about there's a venture
capital fund sure
sure so um f2 we are a seed stage
specialized venture capital firm invest
in israeli early stage companies
we believe that's all about the people
it's all about the founders we put the
founders in the center we do everything
we can to be an extension of their
core founding team we invest in deep
technology
focusing on machine learning ai big data
connectivity
so it's pretty general but it has to be
some kind of aspect
leveraging data or machine learning
internally now i know these are
buzzwords but we do have the
capabilities
um in terms of network and in-house
knowledge to really determine if this is
real technology
and leveraging uh state-of-the-art uh
machine learning and data science
um as part of f2 we also have the
platform called the junction which is a
pre-seed platform
and that's kind of our promise to the
ecosystem so we go much earlier than
anyone else
so besides investing seed stage which is
our core business
we also do pre-seed investments and
that's when we see a team that we feel
the risk
is too high for putting in a couple of
million dollars so we will invite them
to come
sit at our office at the same time and
also
give them all the value to give our
preferred companies
while also investing on a safe
uh a few hundred k's um
and working with them towards the seed
round so tell me a little bit about
about the pre-seed in general it's very
rare that a proper vc goes and
writes precedent checks or puts that at
the forefront and you're actually the
general manager of the junction so
what is the junction and and what is
some of the thought process behind
precedent i i did meet a few
very interesting people back in paul so
that that are working on the assumption
that
you know by by reaching the founders
early and going through the journey and
actually when you reach the
millions of dollars of checks you
actually have much more data to base
your due diligence on i know that 1518
fund it's a relatively new fund they
write
even thousand dollar checks to founders
as a gift no equity just to get to know
them and to go on their journey with
them
but tell me a little bit about what the
thesis behind the junction
i i think that as you described it very
well it's about building a relationship
so um there are founders especially
first-timers
around walking around the ecosystem
trying to raise funds
and it's very important to understand
that they aren't competing
only against the companies that are
doing what they are doing they are
competing against
any other startup that has been
established or went to fundraise in the
past two months
so that's very difficult competition and
the process of raising funds can take
even six months
if like you are really having a hard
time improving the value of what you're
doing and you also need
a team to believe in you what we offer
the junction is a very quick due
diligence process that takes about a
week
and we can offer at the end a hundred
two hundred three hundred thousand
dollars and offer them to come work with
us and build a relationship with the
venture capital firm
so we also provide all this knowledge
and this
knowledge base of how venture capital
firms work and also from
from our experience working with
startups we can advise them
on what's the best thing to do so we
have teams here
that came with these crazy ideas that
all the vcs said like
no and we were able to build a
relationship help them build the
business and develop the idea and then
go and launch
a very successful cd-rom 2019
we had a few companies come through and
i think all of them still one may be out
of the 18 race but all of them raised
seed rounds from
really well known israeli seed funds
so it's about building the relationship
understanding how the visa
the vc ecosystem works bringing the
value add and building the relationship
which is
really really important because they get
to know us and they want to
they will understand if they want to
even work with us in the future and we
get to know them it's a six month
or four month live due diligence it's
like the best thing right both sides
so the preceding though from my
perspective precede
stage really is you know a few people
that that have a passion that
that found a in a cumulative passion
together
and they think they have the right
expertise to go and tackle the problem
they
not usually don't even have a product
and let alone product market fit they go
and they
they want to raise funds that they're
able to come and bring something to
fruition possibly even get a few clients
to raise a proper seed round
is that too early to talk about vc
because
from from one perspective you can say
that at the precinct stage
you really should be focusing on being
with the team together working
day and night and getting the technology
there but it sounds to me that from your
perspective it there
it's not too early because getting those
those relationships
can only be beneficial as you actually
go and and want to raise a meaningful
round later on
yeah i think that these um benchmarks of
if i have a presentation i don't have
customers can i raise if i have hundred
thousand dollars in the mro can i raise
these are discussions that
i think founders try and understand the
formula of how vcs work
there's no formula there are different
risks that
some vcs feel more comfortable with and
some that others don't
and and that's how how it works if i see
a team with um great potential okay and
i feel like i want to work with them
and there's something i can i can i can
do with them and they are targeting an
interesting problem
or an interesting market and i still
aren't quite sure but i feel that if i
can work with them for the next few
months they will be able to build
something
that then i would like to work with them
and it's okay if they have a
presentation and they don't even
they haven't even written a line of code
i have a team here that came with one
idea and they already pivoted uh two or
three times we have a team
that came in and people look at the idea
and they were like
what like how am i even supposed to
analyze this i've never heard of
something like this
and we said okay here's 100k let's work
together fast forward four months
one million dollars uh raised got into
yc starting in two weeks
things you know things develop you just
need to look at the team and see
see the potential and and and take a bet
and what we do here is that
because our core business is seed
investing
a priest investment is kind of i
wouldn't say cheap but
easy for us to to deploy and and take
those kind of bets
betting with the seed round is more
difficult because at the end of the day
we only have 15 bullets
that we can shoot during uh the active
lifetime of the fun
100 so at the end when it comes down to
the seed round
how does the due diligence process look
like for a company that you've been
following along with the junction
through the precede is it basically
you know tell us when you're ready to
raise and then we'll sort of
know already if it's yes or no do you do
the whole process as if it's a new
company how does it actually work
tangibly
yeah so it's actually very different
because we've been working with them we
have these bi-weeklies and these ongoing
discussions we are
super up to date with what's going on
with the company so sometimes we
will even be proactive and come to come
and say hey guys this is the time to
scale
we're going to be leading a four million
dollar round let's go for it
we'll bring all we can also bring the
follower like we will do this for you
um and sometimes they'll be like okay
now we want the money and we'll
sit down and say are we ready are we not
should we offer them another two months
and then go for the raise
so it's kind of this very friendly
discussion
um in order to optimize for both sides
it sounds like it really
mainly it takes away a lot of the stress
of of considering okay are we going to
be able to fundraise and who do we
fundraise from and how do we allocate
now
five months of our ceo's time to just go
on this road show
where you can have this invaluable
partner that not only gives you that 300
in the beginning but it gets you to the
place where you can be confident
yourself about whether you're able to
raise the proper seed round
and by that obviously we're not talking
about the metrics but we're talking
about whether you're actually creating a
viable business
that could actually be being taxed for
right
100 and i know add one more thing
the the you have fun i mean it's fun
the vibe here is incredible i have
different startups coming for
seed around discussions or different
people from the ecosystem
and you come into the office and there's
kind of this this really cool buzz
of like think about we have about at the
moment we have five startups sitting
here okay
one of the startups as i said grew to
almost 12 people they're still in our
office i can't wait for them
i love them they are catching all the
meeting rooms anyway it's like
the spas of something is always
happening all these meeting rooms are
like filled with people
talking and drawing on the boards and do
this and do that and because
and there's kind of a sense of community
and and
we have like happy hours so unfortunate
because i get to work
also at a vc fund but also with like
five subs at the same time so you get
off like this
really um alternative kind of
environment that you're not really used
to when you enter a venture capital
firm's office
i love that so it's additionally and
with a really great segue to working
both with startups and
and in dc you actually it took a little
trip down start a plane now
a a big trip as head of growth at super
wise ai
while also spending time with f2 and
going back to f2 and you mentioned in
april but talk to me a little bit about
this
transition why why even do this and what
have you learned along the way
cool yeah so this has been kind of um
this self-reflection that i've been
having
for the past i don't know a couple of
months and i think i've discussed with
many people in the ecosystem um as an
investor
i've heard many times and i don't have
start-up experience i didn't have until
now
um how can you evaluate a company
without really knowing what a startup is
about maybe you should get some
operational experience
and i've been trying to convince myself
and read studies that there's no
correlation between
people that were operators or investors
that were previously operators and being
a good investor
and i still think that that um it's true
but i thought that i need to gain some
operational experience and feel what it
what what the founders feel so when i
say to a founder you know
start-ups are crazy and it's really hard
work now i can say
yes i'm i'm working a startup and
flip it's like super tough and i've been
learning so much from working with the
superwise team
the company raised 4.5 million dollars
in seed about
a year ago hopefully we'll be going for
an a round soon
the team is about 15 people so it's
exactly the
type of companies that i would like to
work with because these are the
companies we invest in
and of course as a seed investor usually
when companies get to b
c d rounds the seed universe is kind of
a part of the board but the growth
investors take
take lead on on how to navigate the
company so i think it's very important
to
it was important for me at least to
understand what this
what the company looks like so it's like
building the go to market strategy and
talking to customers and and doing these
demos and follow-ups
and suddenly from being on the on the on
the buying side the companies come to me
and say hey can you invest in my company
now i need to reach out to data
scientists and say
please i want to show you a demo of this
product i think you'll
you'll already gain from from using it
and they just don't they just don't
answer they just don't get back to me
um usually they do no i'm just kidding
i'll tell you about 20
of the times they do so so it's a lot of
fun and
you know um closing a customer
paying customer which is a lot for seed
stage
startup it's like the the thrill and the
rush
that you get from something like that is
amazing and i'm really enjoying myself
so it's a great experience
can i imagine what are some of some of
the most meaningful things that you're
taking with you back
to f2 from these from these few months
at superwise because you're mentioning
that you know you
you went through the self-reflective
journey where you're thinking about
what what type of skills or what type of
experiences do you need in order to be a
successful investor in your mind and it
sounds to me like you've had a pretty
impactful experience
with super white so i'd love to hear
some of some of those you know insights
that you've gained along the way
sure so i think the first thing is
hustle
so you sit on the board and you and you
are talking
with your startup and you're trying to
understand what the process is and the
sales machine
the kpis and sometimes as
if i look at myself as a future board
member how how would i
understand that you have to hustle okay
you need to do whatever it takes
to get to the next milestone you don't
have to do things that are scalable i'm
not talking about product or technology
i'm talking more of sales and growth
okay you need to use your connections in
to reach out to people
you need to do whatever it takes to to
score these
customers and only after you experience
onboarding a few customers
then you can really sit down and analyze
what you did
the right way where you made mistakes
and then also kind of build the
segmentation of the customers and how to
approach each of them
and slowly but surely then you start
building the
that marketing sales machine um so
that's the one thing the second
thing is measure everything
measure everything because there are so
many insights inside those numbers
that will really change your perspective
on
how to sell who to sell to
a b testing i think these
sometimes you underestimate them you say
i don't have time for this
and it's a bit slow at the beginning but
i think that if you invest in the
infrastructure
of measuring things it's a great
investment for for the long run
and for the future and for scaling so
um those are my two main takeaways and i
will definitely recommend that to any of
our companies going forward
i love that biggest tips for for
pre-seed companies
for example that are coming to f2
because you really get a chance to both
see companies you know in their you know
early early days and then in the early
days
of of seed right so what are some what
are some tips more for the precinct
because it's very great to be able to
talk to
somebody investing in pre-seed companies
and seeing a lot of them and and seeing
some of the journey that they go through
so what
perhaps what are some of the most
meaningful things that a group of people
can go
can undergo between the preceded seed
that you've been experiencing now and
you can sort of
tell them in advance by the way watch
out this this is going to be important
sure i think um
being in love with your idea is a
challenge
that many companies have
and when you raise precede you need to
understand that you have to be very
flexible
and inputs from the market and this
friction with customers
is super valuable and you have to get
into consideration because you might be
directed in totally different direction
and i think investors when you reach the
seed round
and you pitch them an idea if you can
say i started without with this idea
and now i'm pitching this idea and this
is what i learned
during the past three four months these
are these are the insights i have in the
market
and that's why i pivoted and i chose to
go for for this product
and this solution it as an investor i
would be like
wow okay he actually studied the market
was enough with his idea which means
he's coachable and flexible
and and he is able to kind of productize
the feedback from the customers
for me that's uh that's a very positive
signal
uh as an investor no no it sounds
excellent
i want to thank you for being suggest
with your time 20 minutes go by fast but
but i know that there was so much more
that i wanted to talk about whether it's
the junction f2
where you're headed next but but it
sounds like it's a phenomenal journey
and and very similar to um
i think that i'm on a pretty similar
path of trying to understand what does
it take to to make an
impact whether it's an investing as a
startup as
a learner as anything and it sounds like
these different experiences
um are invaluable and i'm definitely
taking a lot from this conversation so
thank you
but before we leave i have to ask you
for the most important question which is
three words that you would use to
describe yourself
sure so i think the first
word would be loyal
something that i think um one of the
values that i grew up uh
upon being loyal to family and friends
and another
people that i love i'll do i'll do
anything for them and i think it also
um is reflects in how i work with the
companies
and how i work at f2 and
in hebrew says so i think that's part of
really being loyal um the second word
would be
proactive i think that you make
your own luck and you have to be
proactive and just like be out there
expose yourself be vulnerable it's okay
i think you can only gain from from
doing that and
the third would be hustle um
i hustled my way into f2 um a hustle to
uh
um source leads at f2 a hustle that
supervised to uh
to reach these uh um head of data
science and
uh machine learning and it's all about
uh uh the hustle
so you just need to do um hard work and
hustle and do whatever it takes so
those are the three words on my end
thank you very very much this is great
and stay safe and stay healthy
cheers thanks for having me have a good
one of course
you